osama bin javid joins us live from
heitai on the turkey syria border osama
do they have a successor yet
well that is the big question that faces
this elusive organization now which has
now
come like a guerrilla movement from
a an organization which used to carry
its own caliphate
abu bakr al-baghdadi's death uh has also
come
as more leaders of isil have been killed
in the last
few months and days we've also heard
reports from the kurdish fighters saying
that there was another incident
where a spokesman was allegedly killed
near the turkish border as well
so it is an unfolding situation so far
we haven't heard from
isil uh analysts believe that it is
going to be
a situation where a successor will be
announced but it will not be somebody
who is as well known as others have been
because most of most of isil's
leadership has been taken out
uh it is going to be interesting because
isil again
has dis has franchised into many other
areas
outside of iraq and syria and you heard
from abu kar al-baghdadi in his message
last month
where he called for attacks from these
sleeper cells so to speak
across the globe so i think there's a
heightened security after abu bakr
al-baghdadi death
in capitals across the globe and the
world awaits if
iceland has a succession plan also worth
noting
is uh the developments that we've had
from last night turkey has asked for an
investigation
into the movements of abu bakr
al-baghdadi inside syrian territory
turkish president welcoming the move uh
that this is uh
going to be a great achievement in
counter-terror operations between turkey
and its allies but again calling for an
investigation because it wants to figure
out
how was abu bakr al-baghdadi able to go
from place to place
enter syria and then end up close to the
turkish border
osama thanks very much well baghdadi
came from iraq and he declared his
so-called caliphate in mosul
al jazeera's natasha ganem is there
natasha reaction
where you are
we're in the old city of mosul peter and
if you look around
there's devastation is still readily
apparent
the suffering people are feeling is
still quite
acute behind me is the grand mosque of
mosul you can see it was destroyed in
2017 the iraqi government
is accusing isil of being the ones
behind its destruction
but you might say that this mosque is a
very strong
symbol of where isil's reign of terror
began
this is where in 2014 el baghdadi
proclaimed that he was the leader of
isil
the following month isil began its uh
fight to uh form a caliphate it took
control of the city and began its march
across iraq we are speaking to people
here in mosul one man said
we jumped for joy when we heard him we
heard
that he was dead but of course there's
not much joy here
in mosul isil may have been defeated
baghdadi may be dead but people here are
living
with the legacy the psychological trauma
of what happened here
under isil we were just speaking to
these men right here
they're uh standing in front of a bird
shop one man told us
that in 2017 his house was bombed he
lost his eight-year-old daughter
he says i have two sons born since 2017
when the city fell
back into the hands of the iraqi
government and i
can't find a job my son has cancer i
can't get him health care
another man said that everyone he knows
in this city has suffered in some way
at the hands of isil he was reminding us
how when isil initially came to mosul
uh they were using tactics uh sort of
gentle tactics to slowly lure
people into the fold promising jobs
reeling against the government offering
a better way of life and then he said
slowly
bit by bit things became more oppressive
women were told they had to wear the
hijab
smoking was banned people had to wear
certain types of clothing
and then of course the rest is history
we know how isil terrorized the people
of this city
is that natasha the place where he
reportedly did his phd
in islamic studies which gave him in his
mind i guess
religious credibility which was
something that he tried to utilize
when he then went on to set up and run
islamic state
look there is so much unconfirmed
information
about uh l baghdadi and quite honestly i
think the people of mosul want the focus
to be
on the suffering they continue to endure
i just want
ali follow me please you to take a look
this is my
second time in the old city this year
this is what people are dealing with
these are home
this is destruction that the iraqi
government has been unable
to help repair people are literally
living in the rubble
of these buildings they don't have basic
services as you heard they don't have
jobs and this is what the people of
mosul are looking for
they're looking for a path forward a way
past isil
but again as i mentioned peter they are
still very much suffering
so while baghdadi may in fact be dead
they know all too well this does not
mean an
end to this group it's thought that
there are isil sleeper cells
across iraq we know that they have been
launching attacks in the country
and there is a real concern according to
one analyst that now that baghdadi has
been killed
that isil sleeper cells may in fact try
to launch
additional attacks in the coming weeks
to avenge his death
natasha thanks very much